kaiser has announced that the latest
findings from its covert 19 vaccine
study
showed the jab to be more than 90
percent effective
in preventing the disease let's get more
from skies thomas more in
buckinghamshire and
this is obviously good news just how
good news is it
oh it exceeds the expectations of of
many scientists actually
this is a vaccine which is being
developed by a german
biotech company called biontech and then
with the muscle
of pfizer the american pharmaceutical
giant to get it to market
they've been doing tests on more than 42
people and when they looked at those who
had had
two doses of the vaccine against those
who just had a dummy placebo
jab they found that it prevented 90
percent
of the covid19 infections it is a
tremendous result
um very very good protection in the
words of of one scientist
there's more to go though they need to
do further safety analysis that's
expected in the third week of november
they also need to prove that you can
make it at scale
of course we need billions of doses of
this vaccine now the uk
has 30 million uh doses
in its stockpile um that's the deal that
was done by the vaccines task force
over the summer that would be enough for
15 million people around half of those
who would be vulnerable to the disease
there's about 30 million people who are
considered to be at a high need
of the vaccine and of course this is
just one of two
front runner vaccines the other one is
the one developed by
oxford university and astrazeneca that
has been delayed
uh after while they investigated it's a
possible side effect into the vaccine
in the states that is likely to be
reporting in the next few weeks but it
is very very good news
great stuff thomas thanks very much
well how are the markets reacting to
this let's uh talk to sky's ian king
uh what is the reaction well the market
reaction is very very positive indeed i
mean we've seen first of all i should
tell you the oil price has
gone up very heavily the crude oil uh
currently trading around 42
uh dollars a barrel so that's uh up
about
six percent on the session so far
because obviously demand for crude oil
has been absolutely battered
by covid19 in the associated lockdowns
if i talk you through some of the stock
markets we've had some big increases
there
the ftse 100 currently up some five and
a half percent
now that is being led by all of the
stocks that have been absolutely
downtrodden
through the lockdown uh international
airlines group the owner of british
airways for example
that is currently trading up by some 32
32 in a single session absolutely
extraordinary outside the footsie easy
jet again their shares
are up by some 30 percent shares of
wizaire are up by some
18 back in the footsie rolls royce the
aircraft engine maker
their shares are up by more than 20 as
well so very very positive reaction
indeed you saw the picture there across
europe big gains for european equity
markets as well
and the futures markets are indicating a
very strong opening
on wall street we're expecting the dow
jones currently to open up
some hundred points higher that's around
five percent up